hey guys today it is the fourth of
November my name's Jess and you're tuned
into gamespot nice inside news Kaname
has shot down there Los Angeles branch
who worked on Metal Gear Online
effective immediately the publisher
claimed that the studio's closure was
quote due to the product development
resources being restructured into a more
centralized to unit the Los Angeles
studio contributed to the development of
metal gear solid 5 the phantom pain and
metal gear online which is due for
release on PC next January you're a
gamer reported that over 20 jobs were
lost in the process although konami is
not confirmed any numbers specifically
we wish all the best to those affected
the first week of sales for Assassin's
Creed syndicate are down compared to
those of Assassin's Creed unity the
Ubisoft suspect that it's not due to any
fault of syndicate itself as part of the
latest earnings report Ubisoft CFO and
Martinez service syndicates first-week
performance would clearly impacted by
what happened with Assassin's Creed
unity what happened of course being the
rampant and hilarious bugs which plagued
unity at launch and pissed off gamers
everywhere who had excitedly forked over
their hard-earned dollars syndicate had
far less of those issues and it seems
like people responded to that since
sales were boosted during the second
week of release CEO is Guillermo added
that total play time in syndicate is
massively up compared to unity pull out
for and destiny may not have a hell of a
lot in common but it turns out the
shooting mechanics may feel similar
according to Game Informer Bethesda used
destiny as a reference point for fallout
4 shooting the cakes bigger both games
run at 30 frames per second senior
systems designer Josh Hamrick left
Bungie six years ago to join Bethesda
where his role has been focused intently
on tuning full at force firearms in June
Hamrick described the shooting system in
fallout 3 as meth and said they would
improve upon it's possible at four he
explained we started out with fallout 4
knowing that look we can't apologize for
being a role-playing game we have to
build a
person shooter and it needs to be a
really good one we spent a lot of time
on that floor director Todd Howard added
that the game is designed to give plays
the edge if they're using the VAT system
which slows down time and allows players
to target specific enemy body parts and
whose effectiveness is calculated at 4am
or rpg-like systems let me know down in
the comments what your weapon of choice
is going to be before that or you can
end against what we've got stories on
Xbox one's backwards compatibility and
brand new Star Wars movie posters that
is everything I've got for you today as
always let me know what mattered to you
and I will catch you same time tomorrow